GAL VERED: Hello,
everyone, and thank you
for joining this session focused
on making business calls safer
and more effective
with verified calls.
My name is Gal.
I'm a product manager
at Google, and I'm
joined by my teammate Stephen,
who leads our partnerships.
Let me kick things off by
sharing a personal story.
Last month, my bank tried
to call me several times
about the potential fraudulent
activity on my account.
But to be honest,
I just missed those
calls in the sea of spam calls
that I receive every day, I
only realized that something
was wrong after a week when
I tried to use my credit
card and it declined.
Now, luckily, I
had a spare card,
so no big damage was done.
But you can imagine how
stressful the situation
might have been with slightly
different circumstances.
And this story
puts the spotlight
on the importance of
effective communication
over the phone between
businesses and consumers.
So today, I'll start off
by sharing a pain point
we identified in
those communications
and how we went about
developing a solution around it.
And then I'll turn
it to Stephen,
in who will explain how we
work with leading partners
in order to solve these few
pain points to as many users
and as many
businesses as we can.
When we look at the data, we
see that the average person
receives 30 spam
calls each month.
And over 2019, there
was a sizable increase
in phone calls.
The vast majority
of businesses feel
outbound calls are important
for them to meet their customer
service calls.
But here's the problem.
Like me, most consumers simply
don't answer their phone
if they don't
recognize the number.
So there is a massive gap in the
perceived importance of calls
and their actual
effectiveness, which is low
because people don't answer.
So how did we reach this stage?
Today, any device that is
connected to the internet
is capable of making
voice calls through VOIP.
This means that the
good old caller ID
system which displays the
caller [INAUDIBLE] number
can be spoofed very easily.
There's no trust in the system.
So in practice, a
person that sits
in the other side of the world
can make a call to my phone,
and it will look like--
as similar as a call from
my local bank number.
So why would consumers
trust phone calls anymore?
This brings us to
verified calls.
Being helpful and provide a
trust experience for users
is at core with what
we do at Google.
And on the left
of the screen, you
can see how a business
call looks today.
At best, it's an
unidentified call--
nothing personal.
It's just a phone number.
It doesn't mean
anything to the user.
And it looks very similar
to a spam call I receive
or the bank call I missed.
They look exactly the same.
Next you'll see how
verified calls look like.
[RINGTONE]
So let's walk through
the experience.
On the top, we've got a blue
badge with a verified checkmark
and we also display the
name and logo of the brand,
so the user can
know who's calling.
Finally, we allow the user to
state the reason for calling.
And think-- just think
about how wonderful
it would have been if
my bank could show,
hey, this is me calling.
And this is the reason,
about the potential fraud
in your account.
I would obviously pick this
phone call up in a second.
And as you can see, we
included all of the information
that consumers value in order
to make sure we set the call up
for an engaging and productive
communication between the two
sides.
So we call this
product Verified Calls.
So I want to you walk you
through what verified means.
For one, it signals that
the business has passed
Google's verification process.
It also validates that
the call is coming
for a the number is showing.
In other words,
it's not spoofed.
And finally, it gives
the user the information
they need, including
the reason for calling,
so they can make an
informed decision.
Let me walk you through
the verification process.
We use an out-of-band
channel to verify the calls,
meaning that the
phone call still
goes through regular
channels without any change,
and the verification is done
separately through an API.
And to make it even
easier for brands to join,
we work with selected telephony
providers to integrate the API
and perform the verification,
and this minimize the friction
for brands to join.
The first step is to query
the API for reachability data,
and make sure the phone number
can deliver a Verified Calls
experience.
Once this is done,
the next step is
to send Google the brand phone
number, the consumer phone
number, and the call reason, and
Google syncs this information
with the device.
And once the voice
call arrives, the user
will see the Verified Calls UI.
And now I'm excited to share
with you our demo, which
you can see how easy it is
to get your calls verified.
To verify a call,
the first step is
to check if the phone
number is reachable.
As you can see, I
received a response
that the device is
indeed reachable.
So I can continue
to the next step
and send the verified
call's information.
Since I received a 200
response from the server,
I know my data was
saved, and I can go ahead
and make a regular phone call.
And the phone call
will be verified.
[RINGTONE]
Without going into
too many details,
I'll just say that
our services are
powered by the great
infrastructure of Google Cloud.
And I will end my
section by mentioning
that we have designed this
API with our users' privacy
in mind, and Google removes
any personal information
after the verification
is complete.
Now, I am happy
to turn this over
to Steve, that will show
you how we are partnering
with businesses and share their
tremendous interest we've seen.
STEPHEN BROUGH: Thanks, Gal.
As you recall from the
beginning of the presentation,
87% of consumers don't answer
calls from unknown numbers.
This is particularly a
problem for urgent calls,
like Gal's case with his bank.
By verifying the caller with
the logo and other details
like call reason,
our research shows
we can make calls
more trustworthy,
communicate the
relevance to the user,
and ultimately
improve answering.
For the launch of
Verified Calls,
Google has partnered
with leading providers,
like the ones on
this page, to make
calls more trustworthy and
relevant for consumers.
For the latest on all partners
supporting Verified Calls,
please visit the website below.
Our focus on making business
to consumer communications more
trustworthy and engaging
doesn't stop at voice calls.
Back in December 2019, we
publicly launched Verified SMS.
Similar to how Verified Calls
enhances calling experiences,
Verified SMS makes
business SMS messaging
safer and more trustworthy
by adding sender verification
and brand.
Many brands, like
1-800-Flowers, Kayak,
and Google Pay are
already sending messages
with verified SMS, which
is live across nine
countries, including the US and
Canada in North America, Brazil
and Mexico in South America,
UK, Spain, and France in Europe,
and India and the
Philippines in Asia.
And we have more
countries planned in 2020.
For more information
on this service,
please visit the link below.
When we started down this path
of creating both Verified SMS
and Verified Calls we expected
verified communications
to be valuable to both
businesses and users.
In a recent user
sentiment survey in the US
and in Brazil for
verified SMS, we
tested this assumption
and the feedback
was overwhelmingly positive.
In that same survey, we were
both positively surprised
to see how strong user sentiment
was across the customer
lifecycle, particularly areas
that influenced new and repeat
business, like
business consideration,
likelihood to purchase, and
likelihood to recommend.
While we haven't conducted
the same user sentiment
survey for Verified Calls
given how new it is,
anecdotal evidence from
partner discussions
give us confidence that
sentiment will be equally
strong for this service, too.
Verified Calls is first
available in these five
countries--
US, Mexico and Brazil in the
Americas, Spain in Europe,
and India in Asia, with more
countries planned in 2020.
The Google Phone app
and Verified Calls
comes preloaded on many Android
devices in these markets,
including ones from
Motorola, Nokia, Xiaomi,
OnePlus, and, of course, Pixel.
However, if you don't
already have the Google Phone
app on your Android
phone, that's OK.
Coming soon, you'll
be able to download it
from the Play Store.
For partners and
businesses wanting
to take advantage
of Verified Calls,
it's simple to get started.
Just register your
interest in the website,
or email us directly
for more information.
Thank you for joining
Gal and i today
to hear how Verified Calls makes
business calls safer and more
purposeful.
Have a great day.